presented by flight the 2k sports
pregame show along with a big Aristotle
Shaquille O'Neal this is Ernie Johnson
welcome to the NBA on 2k sports you
think most players play their best early
in the season or down the stretch most
play better down the stretch Ernie when
you get into a groove as you go other
guys aren't really coming in a hundred
percent shape when that news came down
that day how surprised were you I was
surprised Donnie but not really he's
born in Cleveland raised include what do
you make of that I call it the iron leg
jumper Ernie an iron leg I'm a ein as an
Einstein but take away at this time if
you were gonna have some home cookin
what would it be fried chicken macaroni
and cheese oh man now you're talking my
language
that right there Ernie is wool did you
see that dunk right there I was there I
remember I was there - that's the best
dunk ever you can play with a high of
God I said I want to see that is that
like a motorcycle or something - no
Esther wall more wow what kind of lot
more do you have oh yeah and we just
don't care let me stay home oh oh oh
what if you were playing on Christmas
what was that like
oh I love it are only big bands bit
games and then when I call them back
goes doo doo dee this number has been
changed but no re seriously what I like
about this guy he's humble if he doesn't
do his own horn but he doesn't think
he's right all the time
simple math honey I just picked one of
my degrees to pull from if4 would you
like to build them yes like what a
street bachelor's master's and doctorate
do you do your best studio work early in
a show or late in the show well I'm the
master of the groom especially when I
got you into drums drums
groove please I gotta go